for a significant portion of my
childhood in the 1970s and 1980s we
lived on a street called Glacier Pass in
a subdivision called the hills of
Delafield and technically speaking it
was in the township of Delafield it was
actually much closer to Wales just to
the South the village of Wales where I
went to elementary school and actually
my kindergarten was there as well and
um you know it was sort of like on the
border you could say and it when we
moved in we were one of the first
families to move into this subdivision
it was pretty vacant and I should tell
you a little bit of background so that
area which they now call Lake country is
a part of southeastern Wisconsin that
was until you know that time mostly
farmland or land that had gone back to
Meadows and sometimes even scrub woods
and then there were you know forests and
things like that all over the place and
quite a few of the farmers you know had
decided to subdivide their their land
that meant that they sell they sold it
to developers or they developed it
themselves and you'd put in like a road
that tended to be kind of winding and
there'd be you know cul-de-sacs coming
off of that other roads in our
subdivision you know we had gray fox run
and Hidden Hollow and I forget what the
other one was and so you have this big
long winding road that connected to a
State Highway 83 and actually our
entrance was across from the entrance
for
another complex that included the Wales
school for boys which is long since
closed and that was a maximum security
facility for juveniles uh so like the
worst of the worst were just across the
highway from us and you know so these
these roads were made and you know they
were typically uh you know the kind of
whitish asphalt that you would see
um and and you know then they would hope
that people would buy them and my dad
who was working as a tax attorney for
touch Ross here in Milwaukee not far
from where we currently live uh he had
you know relocated us to this suburb
called Thiensville where we were living
in an apartment complex and he and my
mom wanted to build a house and buy some
land and so that's exactly what they did
they bought a lot one acre and then you
know they had a contractor who built the
house and when the house was built you
know it was as uh on the outside it
looked like it was completely done but
like a lot of the houses around there it
was It was kind of done in stages so you
put your house up and you know the
fireplace was completely done and some
of the the finishing was done but there
were no carpets it was all just you know
bare plywood floors or whatever whatever
that that board is that they were using
because we didn't have carpet quite yet
I think the kitchen did have the
linoleum down in there and the bathrooms
did as well but it took several years
for us to get carpet it was quite cold
in there especially those first couple
Winters and similarly the yard you know
took a lot of development
planted grass lots of landscaping you
know my dad actually bought sod for the
front yard and we you know we all had to
help out with unrolling it even though I
was like you know maybe six or seven at
the time and you know so everything was
done bit by bit by bit and you could say
the same thing about the subdivision
itself I think that they had planned for
people to start moving in much more
quickly than they actually did so for a
long time you know the closest neighbor
was about a quarter of a mile away and
then there were some you know further on
up in different places and slowly over
time things started filling in right So
eventually we had houses next to us on
both sides and I'm not so much in this
story thinking about the house itself
maybe I'll do some other things about
about that
I want to tell you about what it was
like as a kid growing up in the natural
environment because you know with this
road right we had all the houses along
the road and then behind us we had what
you call a ridge line which is like you
know one Long Hill the spine of which
extended out for probably a mile or so
right and it was wooded and there were
you know some parts were a little bit
rougher some parts were easy to get
through there were trails that had been
made by deer in many places and this
Woodland area was like our our big
playground it was behind all of the
houses
and we would go do stuff and if it
wasn't Woods it was kind of prairie with
you know grasses growing and bushes and
sometimes they were like you know kind
of an in-between thing lots of
honeysuckle for example which is quite
fun to to work with you know you can
Nestle underneath it sumac you know all
these sort of cool things and they were
you know massive trees as well
um you know Oaks and uh Birches and
poplars and all sorts of others as well
so it was kind of a cool place to grow
up because we had this long backyard you
know so the the house was uh in the
front yard was higher than the backyard
the backyard kind of sloped down and
then it you know moved up into the hills
and then if you got on the top of the
hill you could go down the other side of
the hill and then you were in this
massive Prairie that had you know some
parts were elevated some parts were for
depressions and it was just like a Sea
of Grass except that there was a massive
pile of stones Each of which was about
you know this big or so that some farmer
had left there at one time and then
there was a depression that would
sometimes fill in with water so we had
you know what we called our little Pond
even though it was it really wasn't a
pond it wasn't fed by anything other
than rain and it you could walk or you
know ride your bikes or run or do
whatever else you wanted along this
Prairie which had its own Trails which
were mostly made by the deer again I
think and it would go all the way to
Highway 18.
Highway 18 and 83 come together on one
corner of the village of Wales and back
then you know there wasn't a lot of
traffic there wasn't a lot going on but
at that corner of 83 and 18 there was a
shop you know like a basically like a
garage right where they would repair
cars and change tires and stuff like
that and then right down from it there
was the Kickapoo gas station and County
Store
and back then there were you know gas
pumps everything was uh leaded at the
time that I moved in and then unleaded
gas started to become uh popular as well
um and interestingly at first it wasn't
even a store you could say it was like a
store Front there was like a a place
like a booth essentially and a person
would be in there and you could see all
the stuff behind him cigarettes and
candy and you know various other things
and you know you'd go up and you'd pay
them he had a window that he'd open up
and then like if you wanted candy you'd
say hey I want some now and laters I
want some of that gum over there and
then he'd hand it to you and you'd hand
them your money and that was that you
couldn't go in a store because there
wasn't there wasn't actually a way to go
in and then of course it got expanded
later on uh within my my time as a kid
there but at first that's that's the way
it was and you know we just called it
the Kickapoo store and so we called this
entire are probably like a good mile or
so of of trails in between that that
Ridge line behind our houses and the
store on Highway 18. we called it the
Kickapoo Trails we weren't very
imaginative kids right because where we
would take those trails to get to the
Kickapoo store where then if we had any
change we would buy ourselves some candy
and I'll actually engage in a little bit
of a digression so my dad had a den that
you know a den is like a special room
set aside for some particular purpose he
didn't actually use it much because I I
don't think he had any particular
hobbies that you know couldn't be done
in the basement we had a workbench down
there and we did our slot racing down
there and other things as well and a lot
of what we did actually was you know
camping and boating and things like that
but he had a den and when he would come
from home from work he would take off
his work pants and hang him over a chair
and sometimes I'd go in there and reach
into his work pants and if he had any
change I'd take the change you know like
nickels and dimes and quarters and stuff
like that and then I would use that to
buy candy at the store my dad didn't
really care you know he didn't keep
track of that sort of thing
so anyway
um we had a lot of fun and in in part
because when we were kids particularly
during the summer unless it was like
raining really hard we were expected to
be outdoors for most of the time I mean
there would be some exceptions if it was
a super hot day we could go do stuff in
the basement nobody had air conditioning
back then so you'd go in the basement
because it was nice and cool and you
know maybe you'd you know draw with
crayons or play with other stuff or who
knows what you would do right and
in general we were expected to be
outside you know and so sometimes we'd
have our bikes or sometimes we would
just be walking around
and much of what we would do is just
screw around in the natural environment
that we we had I mean we had some toys
like for example
I mentioned the bikes you could ride
around on all these cool trails and
stuff like that and you know we we did
have a few like
um fake guns for playing various things
some of them were like you know space
oriented things I remember I had this
one from like I think space 1999 and it
would shoot these discs and you could
angle it so that they was they would go
around not quite corners but they could
hit people
but much of what we did was just take
things from the physical environment and
do stuff with them so we did a lot of
like making forts now the forts would
often be we would find a construction
site where something was being built in
we'd steal all the pallets that were
being left there and then we'd use those
for making for us but we do we do other
stuff as well any scrap wood that we
could find much of our Fort would be
branches that we would take from things
sometimes we get shovels and dig you
know halfway down so the fort could be a
little bit bigger we would get sticks
and turn the sticks into just about any
anything you could think of laser rifles
swords for being Knights you know
whatever whatever you want right
and so we did a lot of like hiking and
exploring we did a lot of
um playing you know spy games like boys
spy on the girls girls spy on the boys
little kids play on the big kids big
kids spy on the little kids we also you
know would have like rock fights not a
great idea you actually got you know uh
hit with one one time that that I had to
get three stitches in my head but you
know we're dumb kids that we if we
didn't use rocks it'd be snowballs or
you know balls of mud or stuff like that
so we spent a lot of time traipsing
around in these trails and we also did
in the winter and also then later in the
summer a lot of using the hills and many
of these were you know quite wooded for
um sledding or doing things similar to
sledding
so you know if you've got nice Hills you
get a sled and you it's snowy you just
go down them and we would you know
sometimes just just do plain old
sledding or sometimes we'd make ramps
out of you know snow and then we'd put
some water on it to freeze it with ice
sometimes we would um have snowball
fights as we're sledding down or we
would play what we called Smash Up Derby
where everybody's like trying to bump
into each other's sleds and knock each
other off and one of the hills behind my
place was one of the best hills for
sledding except you had to be a little
bit careful because there was a trail
really well established Trail and it
came down the hill but then it had kind
of a curve to it and you had to you had
to be careful because if you went off
that curve you're going right into a
bunch of bushes and maybe even hitting a
tree and you could go fast down that
hill so we did a lot of that
and we also
um
we took a wagon now like a kid's wagon
one of those red wagons that you see
and we would ride that down Hills we put
like a cushion in it didn't have any
shock absorbers or anything like that I
mean it was like going on a roller
coaster ride basically we're really
lucky we didn't get hurt more than more
often than we did or more seriously than
we did and we would do this down you
know on the roads too we would ride the
wagon we'd go up to one of the big hills
and ride the wagon down the road and he
would steer using the handle on the
wagon that's not a good steering wheel
right it turns the two front wheels and
you could easily flip the whole thing
over well we would do this going down
the hill behind my house which was just
dirt and rocks and wood and grass right
so you get at the top of the hill and
sometimes we'd have like two kids in the
wagon as well really really stupid no
helmets no nothing right and you would
just uh you know the you didn't even
need like to push off gravity itself
would suck you right down and so we did
a lot of a lot of that as a matter of
fact I want to go back to the sledding
as well
so there were all these barbed wire
fences that were you know a legacy of
the farming days and you had to be kind
of careful not to run into them because
you know sometimes they they would be
still still there and one of the hills
I don't know why we did this and why we
didn't just like take the fences down or
something you had to be careful to make
sure you would break before you would
get to the barbed wire fence otherwise
you would hit the barbed wire fence
while you were sledding and you know we
could have cut ourselves up pretty bad
but we we you know we just yeah just
don't hit it it's kind of funny the way
that we were so lackadaisical about
safety stuff so anyway we would uh do
all of these cool things there was also
like a massive rope swing somebody I
don't know who it was I think it might
have been Tony scafito's dad there's a
massive massive Oak uh behind our place
and the scaffitos lived right next door
to us
so anyway there was a rope and it had to
be at least an inch thick that was uh
thrown up oh way way way high over one
of the big thick branches and then tied
off and so we could we could take that
we would run and grab that rope and then
swing way up you know like 10 12 feet in
the air and then come back down you know
and swing back the other way sometimes
we would grab it and swing up and then
let go and go flying and then you know
hit the ground uh somewhere and you know
hopefully not not break a leg or
something like that
um and that was that was a lot of fun as
well we did a lot of great stuff we'd
have picnics out in the woods you know
and when we had a dog too well actually
all the the neighbors dogs loved going
out in the woods it was a lot of fun and
you know we'd hike around and you know
explore and make new trails of our own
and you know sometimes we'd pretend that
we were pirates or
um
that we were in Battlestar Galactica or
Star Wars or that we are Knights on some
sort of mission I mean we would just use
our imagination about what it is that we
were doing and then of course as we got
older we started you know it started
turning into something where our
juvenile delinquency became something
you know we we started uh pretending to
smoke we would steal matches and then
take the straw the straw you could like
you know suck air through and we would
light it up and pretend like we were
smoking and you know
um we'd cool off and all that sort of
stuff I remember uh you know
um when we started to discover swear
words we'd go out in the woods and swear
at each other and stuff like that and of
course there was you know some some uh
you could say drinking and fooling
around and stuff like that as we got
older and older because I I lived there
until I was about uh 17 or so and I you
know we we knew these woods and that
area sort of like the back of our hands
and it's interesting because
um
at first there was no Road in the
Kickapoo Trails behind us and then they
made a road and the road went past that
rock pile and we kind of didn't take
much notice of it because only one
Family actually moved in for a while in
the wooded part at the very end of the
road and then another family moved in on
this High Hill area and we're like oh
things are starting to kind of fill in
there but our own subdivision was by the
1980s becoming more and more packed with
uh people as all the Lots sold and
people built houses and there were more
and more kids and you know like an
entire neighborhood uh and you could say
like ecosystem right
clicks could form people uh had their
their people that they liked and they
didn't like and all of that and you know
that area behind our houses was still
the the Woodland the meadow that we
could play in and for a while even uh
there was water like one year super
heavy rains and the backs of a lot of
our yards filled up with water and some
people actually like caught fish and put
the little fish in there until
unfortunately it dried up and the fish
died
um but you know this was like an area
for all of us neighborhood kids to
continually explore and redevelop and
play in and do all sorts of fun cool
stuff and I guess you know kept us out
of our parents hair they kind of knew
more or less where we were although we
were ranging over a several square mile
area where you could have you could say
it was like a a giant Park that we all
had access to that was completely
unofficial and really just the product
of Farmland going fallow
so you know this was uh you know for a
long time a really nice
perk of living where we did uh this un
unused land it wasn't unclaimed of
course because people did own it and
then it started to fill in by the time
that I was you know
17 and we moved out much of the Kickapoo
Trails had been turned into Lots which
people had put houses on the roads had
expanded you couldn't walk anymore all
the way from our place to the Kickapoo
trails and subsequently to that they
actually filled in even more stuff they
cut the they cut all the trees down and
uh you know leveled off the top of the
the hills and put houses up there so now
all of that is is uh quite different
than it used to be there are still some
patches along the road where you can see
the grasses there are still some trees
here and there but it's definitely not
what it used to be and you know I do
remember my dad actually before he died
he he died very young in 1982
when I was 11.
um so you know we'd only been there
since I think 1974 early 1975. he was
already looking for uh a place to build
a new house that would be kind of out in
the middle of nowhere without so many
neighbors I don't think that he was he
was quite so big on the subdivision life
which is interesting because he grew up
in a subdivision in the suburbs of
Chicago so maybe he was trying to get
away from that but
um this was a really important part of
my life I was really fortunate to grow
up in a place where you know it was
relatively safe I mean there were like
you know you know we'll keep an eye out
sometimes for wandering dogs at certain
times and of course you know we could
easily injure ourselves in a variety of
different ways but for the most part it
was uh it was pretty safe and
um we had you know sort of very
extensive experience in Woodcraft and
you know being able to figure out what
to to do all day in the middle of nature
so like you know when we went on camping
trips or something it wasn't really that
big of a transition compared to kids who
you know were from the town or from
cities or stuff like that and and I
remember it very fondly it was a great
uh time and way to to have a childhood
and slowly grow up I was very fortunate
to have the opportunity to do that so I
thought I would uh tell you a little bit
about that and share it with you and
maybe some of you had similar
experiences or maybe you didn't but that
was a very important part of my life
that I I carry around with me everywhere
I go in my memories